hey there i'm roger craig smith uh i am
going to be answering the 20 most
searched sonic the hedgehog questions
and
who knows how this could go it could
just blow up in my face it probably will
good luck everyone goggles up
this is a good question this is is sonic
the hedgehog real
of course as far as talking blue
hedgehogs go
sonic's pretty real i think i hope
i found you faker faker
i think you're the fake hedgehog around
here
can sound like the hedgehog swim i think
we all know the answer to that
it's probably a form of swimming he
floats actually more he sinks
and goes
can't sound like the hedgehog escape a
black hole no well
not well ooh yeah
fastest thing alive that's interesting
that would indicate
that astrophysics has not factored in
sonic
into black hole theory let me be the
first to say
yeah he can take that all you smarty
pants
astrophysicists with your theories what
about the sonic theory right
no way i can't believe this
can sonic stop time um
[Music]
i don't know i think uh i think cher
said it best when she said if i could
turn
back time and then i don't remember the
rest of that song
so no and i don't know where i'm gonna
go with this so
i think cher can but sonic can't i'm
assuming he can't i feel like he would
have done it by now
can sonic fly i'd kind of like to think
that what sonic is doing is essentially
it's low-level flying at all times he's
just got his landing gear down the
entire time so yeah he's flying
and he puts his arms back and does that
whole anime run thing so yeah
i think that's you know why do they put
their hands out like that for the anime
run if they don't feel like what they're
doing is actually flying
on the ground
ken sonic time travel this goes right
back to the uh the black hole theory
uh question um i'm assuming at this
point he can because if he can escape a
black hole then he could probably
survive it
if he wanted to go through and then open
up a that's how that works right i think
wormholes and time and stuff like that
yeah
time space continuums and all that whole
thing so sure yeah he's time traveling
can sonic phase through walls no
what's sonic the hedgehog are you coming
in for a hard landing tails you got me
covered
roger who's roger he's talking to me
thanks buddy i'm
the the hedgehog i guess i'm maybe the
boom sonic i guess would that be
who knows how you know i just like to
think i'm i'm one of
many talented people who have had the
honor of
voicing the talking blue hedgehog so
i guess i'm that blue sonic that
hedgehog
guy next question what is
what's sonic's real name larry i know
right
larry who'd have thought but it's not
larry the hedgehog
it's just larry he's that big it's kind
of like cher
why am i bringing up share that's twice
and one at la and
i'm not even wrong
[Music]
no larry just larry just larry it's
canon now
i said it it's on the internet it lives
it's like you know
it's larry i know right who'd have
thought
what is sonic's you know what is sonic's
what's sonic's birthday i should know
this because there is an actual
although i will say this there's usually
a little bit of controversy
over what they would technically say is
sonic's birthday
based upon the release of the first game
based upon the release of the uh
yeah so um let's just go with january
1st
um 19 something i guess
you know i should know that i really
should you know if i was
smarter i'd tell them to edit this and
i'll just like pick up my phone and
google it
and then just you know nonchalantly go
oh 1993.
oh um what is sonic's birthday it's the
the 23rd of june it's just i i mean
i voiced the character for a decade i
would know that and so yeah 22
3rd of june is uh is sonic's birthday
yeah happy birthday sonic hope you like
this
like it i love it
where's sonic the hedgehog like right
now does anyone really know
is that an existential question where is
he
in time where is he emotionally
this is some deep stuff i mean the
internet is getting really
deep with their sonic questions where's
sonic the hedgehog
no one may ever know really where does
sonic live
wherever sonic wants what's
sonic's phone number 867-5309-99
867-5309
who voices sonic the hedgehog it's a
pretty good question
who is sonic's girlfriend not going to
go anywhere near this one tsunami fans
not going anywhere near this not gonna
touch it nope
10 foot pole not going anywhere nope
sonic's girlfriend nope
don't even know what you're talking
about how about this weather lately am i
right kind of crazy
escape no no i was just searching for
more of that fan fiction of yours
ooh son amy spicy
how old is sonic oh man well technically
almost 30
i guess we're coming up on 30 years for
the anniversary of the character so
this is a but i know the controversy
that will be
sparked from this because i've heard
throughout my tenure uh just
how old sonic is supposed to be and it
ranges
all over the place so i'm gonna go with
30 years old let's go with 30. let's
just play it safe because that's what
you can't argue with that
how do you draw sonic the hedgehog very
poorly i cannot draw to save my life
who would win in a fight sonic or mario
come on
come on come on internet sonic all the
way
unless i was charles martine and then
i'd have to say mario you know
but let's just go with it's me sonic the
winner of that fight
it's a me sonic
who would win in a race sonic or the
flash sonic
clearly because he's not trying as hard
you know what i mean his name is just
sonic the hedgehog
it's not fasty mcfasterson or you know
the flash like you know cause really
like you need to try that hard like
what's your name the flash you know like
you gotta be fast so you named yourself
something zippy
no sonic sonic the hedgehog is is gonna
win the race every single time
yeah take that flash you're too slow
why does the president have a picture of
sonic on his desk
our current president or was this when
did this question get asked
why does the president have a picture of
sonic on his desk
wouldn't it be weird if it was lincoln
how crazy would that be
that would answer our space-time
continuum traveling time-traveling sonic
question wouldn't it
if only it were like old times so
there's a video game
that has that okay okay
that i still i still stand by my answer
what if it was lincoln well there you
have it there's the 20 most
asked sonic the hedgehog questions and i
think we've solved everything
all the world's problems everything
solved by this little bit
so if you want to ask me directly you
could follow me on social media
at roger craigsmith uh instagram
and twitter uh i have a website
rogercrakesmith.com i don't do much on
there
but you could go and be woefully
disappointed by it
so there's that and you could probably
ask me on social media
why haven't you updated your website and
that'd be the 21st
most asked sonic the hedgehog question
stay safe out there guys wear a mask
please thank you
[Music]